le bâtiment secteur en crise à la crise
du bâtiment aujourd'hui se trouve plus
dans la pénurie de main d'oeuvre que
dans l'activité puisque en côte d'or
aujourd'hui on a une activité plutôt
soutenu mais effectivement on peine à
recruter de la main d'oeuvre pour la
réalisation de chantiers
pourquoi ce manque de madère ça vient
sans doute d'une mauvaise image du
bâtiment donc effectivement j'attribue
ça une méconnaissance des métiers du
bâtiment d'où l'intérêt des journées
comme celle-ci c'est de faire connaître
aussi les différents métiers du bâtiment
de redorer un petit peu de montrer que
les métiers du bâtiment sont des acteurs
dans notre vie quotidienne et que c'est
quand même très intéressant de pratiquer
un métier dans lequel on voit ce qu'on
réalise au quotidien le bâtiment un
secteur qui évolue et à les innovations
faites par les industriels
d'autre part ya les innovations au
quotidien dans la mise en oeuvre de ces
matériaux et puis des nouvelles
technologies telles la domotique
aujourd'hui le bim qui sont des systèmes
qui nous permettent de concevoir en 3d
et de faire évoluer le chantier aussi
par l'intermédiaire du 3d tout au cours
de l'exploitation de la réalisation du
bâtiment